The most important election
in America is tomorrow...
Get out and vote for Roy Moore.
...so I went down
to Alabama last week
to see how the people
were fighting back
against the liberal media's
despicable lies.
I read a poll
that said that 40%
of the people of Alabama
are more likely
to vote for Roy Moore
after allegations that he
sexually molested teen girls.
We're seeing
Roy Moore supporters
actually say they're now
more likely to vote for him
because of the allegations.
So I'm going to talk
to Republicans
to see how they defeated
fake news yet again.
Road trip, baby!
Uh, but Jordan wouldn't let me
rent a Dodge Charger,
uh, so I had to rent
a Chrysler Pacifica.
It sucks.
(bleep) him.
There's a lot of fake news
going around.
I think it was just an attack,
a way to eliminate somebody
that they knew
they couldn't beat.
Even if it's true,
um, I don't want to give up
a Senate seat.
Right.
These Alabamians
weren't going to fall
for some bogus media narrative
built off of evidence,
facts and eyewitness accounts.
But was there anything
Roy Moore could do
to lose their vote?
I mean, there's murder,
there's...
If I had been a victim, I
certainly wouldn't vote for him.
So that's nine people
that probably aren't voting
-for Roy Moore?
-Well, absolutely.
If they came out and they said,
"He shoplifted."
I wouldn't vote for him then.
'Cause these are the, um, people
we want our kids to look up to,
and I think they should live
to a higher standard.
-Amen to that.
-Of course, everybody knows
that shoplifting is
the lowest form of humanity.
Are you more excited
to vote for Roy Moore
after these allegations
came out?
Yes. It's like, um, being a mom,
you don't want to see
your children bullied.
You got after the bully.
-He's older than a child.
-Right.
-And he's being accused
of going after children, -Right.
-but that's.. but he denied it.
-Right.
Exactly.
The real victim is Roy Moore.
How can anyone survive
under these attacks?
He was going to have
to live with this
for the rest of his life.
(horn honking)
(whooping)
-(honking continues)
-Yeah! Yeah!
Roy Moore loves kids.
Sadly, some young people
in Alabama have been abused
and taken advantage of
by the mainstream media.
Do you believe the allegations
against Roy Moore?
-I certainly do.
-You believe those women?
-Yes.
-He denied the allegations.
And?
There's the witnesses
at the mall,
there's, you know,
the witnesses of the employees,
there was that security guard
who did say that it happened,
you have the victims themselves.
Just disregard all of that
on his word?
Yeah. It's he said/they said.
Nothing riles me up more
than thinking
about the fake news media.
They love to use facts
and evidence against people,
and I hate it!
Why can't they go to Canada?
Go to Canada!
Go to the ocean.
Drown yourselves.
Anyway, it's fun
to be in Alabama. Roll Tide.
The only way
to fight the MSM lies
is to hear the unfiltered truth
straight
from the horse's mouth.
The horse in this analogy
is human stallion Steve Bannon.
(neighs)
And, just my luck,
he was speaking
at a Roy Moore rally.
Fake news. Fake news.
You're fake news, dude.
Everybody's fake news.
You're fake news.
Oh, whoa. No.
Sorry, that-that's Fox.
They're good.
Here I am at the rally.
Look at all this excitement.
They're here
to support their man,
to defeat the liberal media,
to defeat the fake news bias
and narrative
that's been shoved
down the people of Alabama.
Come on.
We're not going
by what the liberal news says.
I could give a damn less
about what they say.
-Shame on them.
-Yeah. -Shame.
-Shame, shame, shame.
-Yeah.
It's just, uh, an attack.
Uh, it's just dirty politics.
The allegations
are kind of ridiculous.
-For... It was 40 years ago.
-Yep.
-So what if he dated teenagers?
I dated teenagers when I was 30.
-Exactly. You take... You...
-Roy was... No, I was 20.
-Roy was 30. So... -I... Yeah.
He was 30, and then...
-But they were 14.
-Exactly.
Whatever the numbers were,
they were adding up for me.
-I thought you were Eric Trump.
-I mean...
-that's one of the nicest
compliments -(chuckles)
-I've ever received.
-Well...
I was having
the time of my life.
It felt great
to have everybody agree with me
and not challenge my support
of an alleged child predator.
I think common sense tells you
-there's nothing to this.
-Exactly.
Common sense tells you
one man denied it.
Nine women said it happened,
-but he denied it, so...
-Yeah.
Go, Roy Moore.
Judge Roy Moore
has more honor and integrity
in a pinky finger
than your entire family has
in its whole DNA.
(cheering, applause)
Judge Roy Moore.
That's the man with all
the allegations, right there.
Look at Roy Moore on stage.
He's not touching anybody.
Where's that story, CNN?
They think people in Alabama
are stupid,
that they're gonna bring this up
a month before the election
and we're gonna fall for it? No.
-You hear that, liberal media?
-(chuckles)
People are more excited to vote
for an alleged predator
right now.
They're not less excited.
-Exactly.
-Absolutely.